bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video io sono fa vj
scusatemi se non ho fatto uscire video
in questi due giorni ma veramente dopo
il video dei 10.000 ho dovuto prendere
una pausa eta diciamo perché mi ha
portato via un casino di tempo e di tale
video dei 10.000 comunque nel frattempo
siamo arrivati anche a 11 quindi tempo
di andare in bagno e tornare siamo già
15.000 devo caricare il secondo video
speciale va beh a parte questo veramente
raga grazie grazie veramente non so cosa
dire per riprendermi da questa pausa vi
annuncio che sabato uscirà un video
speciale che aspettavate tutti
tantissimo e in più inizierà un'altra
serie prima possibile adesso vedrò
quando il fondo iniziale va beh non vi
spoiler ho più nulla andiamo avanti dove
c'erano rimasti c'era sta roba che non
mi chiedete che cos'era perché non l'ho
capito e dovevano prendere la st wright
perché ci dobbiamo sbloccare i nuovi
mondi che ce ne servono 24 e meno
abbiamo 22
ok iniziamo sono tra noi sono tra noi
cose i teletubbies
guardatevi intorno allarga perché ok
cosa succede è crollato un ufo ok penso
che siano tra noi effettivamente gli
alieni allora abbia gli alieni sono tra
noi ok sotto mentite spoglie prima paura
delle luci intense
allora abbiamo un gatto un bebè è edward
di twilight ok perfetto
dobbiamo dato che c'è edward di twilight
ne approfitto metto il sole come luce
intensa così almeno luccica oddio oddio
ci ho azzeccato c'azzecca lo sapevo io
lo sapevo ma è inutile che fate quella
faccia lo sapevo l'alieno successivo ha
paura dei rumori forti
ok allora direi di mettere una cassa ma
di quelle potenti proprio quelle tipo
tomorrowland cassa contenitore casa
audio vai
cioè michael con dio era il bebè
perfetto l'ultimo dire che il gatto per
esclusione
trovala viene impostata e terrorizzato
dall'acqua ma si vede è l'unico rimasto
vabbè comunque gatti odiano l'acqua che
lo sapevamo già e allora direi diluvio
perfetto anzi no aspettate un attimo
rievoco lo tsunami zona tsunami perfetto
lo tsunami in uno stagno come fa esserci
lo tsunami in uno stagno poi ve lo
spiegate ma vabbè perfetto l'ho trovato
basa bastava un bicchier d'acqua alla
fine l'ultimo alieno soffre di vertigini
perfetto ragazze soffre di vertigini la
cosa che mi viene in mente epica secondo
me è questa allora elicottero è
l'elicottero non è per lui ma è per me
subito dopo no le ricordo non l'ho preso
io ma dio mio santissimo come fai ad
avere le vertigini se ce l'ho io
l'elicottero me lo spieghi ok
vabbè l'abbiamo in mente comunque di
legarlo ad una catena che poi legava
l'elicottero per portarlo tipo fuori
dall'atmosfera terrestre però
evidentemente lui soffre di vertigini
solo a guardarmi quindi va beh direi di
prendere la site se riesco a scendere
perfetto per fece la l'albero c'era
l'albero giustamente non l'avevo visto e
ci siano ventitreesima starai tragga ne
manca una e poi posso sbloccarmi tutte
le zone nuove se devo essere sincero
raga non so dove prendere quest'ultima
cos'è questo devo baciare qualcuno
ok e vissero per sempre felici e addio
addio ma che cazzo è successo se
fulminata la principessa racca e morta
una storia d'amore comunque migliore di
quella di twilight
comunque direi di proseguire mi dispiace
ti ho reso felice per mezzo secondo
almeno quello c'è un tele o cazzo è
morto anche maxwell e il telefono ci sta
massacrando è un killer
e vabbè continua oddio sono morto per un
telefono
vabbè raga direi di proseguire a sto
punto non facciamoci domande andiamo
avanti
mi manca una st wright praticamente per
sbloccarmi tutta sta roba
direi di andare nel veliero 2 pronti
anche se ci sono già stato ma voi non
l'avete visto perché faceva parte di
quell episodio che non avevo caricato
perché non mi piaceva come episodio
e allora direi di di provare veliero due
ponti magicamente avevo fatto avevo
preso un asta wright su due che si
possono prendere qui quindi me ne manca
una non so precisamente dove per adesso
andiamo a vedere allora innanzitutto
direi di provare a farmi volante post
parto materno
c'è allora maxwell fino adesso è rimasto
post parto raga gossip maxwell è incinta
senza motivo ma per dire di continuare
lo stesso lara volante volante perfetto
è veloce veloce ok
così almeno me ne vado dovunque alla
velocità della luce cos'è questo video
del corpo è difettoso dammi qualcosa per
costruire un buon nido una gru perfetto
vabbè dai raga cosa stupidissima che
cassano
da adesso in avanti corvi si
costruiscono i nidi con le gru ma quante
cose della natura ci fa scoprire scriver
nozze fantastico
vabbè dai ragazzi rei di proseguire
andiamo al di sotto c'è kasper che mi
chiede di fare una sfida per un'asta
wright ed è l'ultima che mi manca per
sbloccarmi dalla nuova zona allora
all'equipaggio è successo qualcosa di
terribile spesso nella maledizione so
come si fa perché ho visto pirati dei
caraibi quindi ce la posso fare allora
questo cos'è cos'è oddio c'è ancora lo
scheletro di skyrim c'è uno zombie c'è
un qualcosa che non so cos'è e io sono
diventato un fantasma palesemente finto
all'equipaggio è stata lanciata una
maledizione dai a ogni membro qualcosa
qui era interessato al guerriero del
gruppo piacevano le armi medievali direi
che per l'ennesima volta la spada
gommosa può tornarci utile perfetto si
ok ma raggaeton questo gli devo dare un
martello va beh non importa al membro
successivo piaceva acconciare i peli del
volto in vari modi ma è ora quasi pelato
dagli dei peli del volto di cui può
essere fiero barba finta barbatelli se
va a era ok perfetto sempre una versione
di sandokan con la barba va bene brava
hai spezzato una tale all'inizio del
prossimo membro piaceva la propria
immagine ma la maledizione ne ha fatto
troppo scomparire il corpo mostra lì
come ok allora sto punto direi rifare
uno specchio perché altro non mi viene
in mente perfetto 3 maledizioni meno il
prossimo membro e dalle più intelligente
del gruppo la maledizione gli ha tolto
cervello usa il blocco appunti per
istruirlo ok perfetto
direi di materializzare un professore a
stop un professore traps ore
raga come cazzo scrivo vabbè lasciamo
stare professori insegnante vai in
segnali cos'è è diventato una sorta di
babbo natale delle arti marziali
l'ultima maledizione riguarda capitano
della nave ricongiungerà polly chi cazzo
è poli rega non ho idea di chi sia polli
sinceramente ragazza a sto punto direi
la gara mi ricorda un casino tipo il
film di gas perché vedevo da piccolo e
lei quali perfetto sono un vero pirata
fantasma e tu sei su una vera nave
fantasma oddio ragazzi amo invasi siamo
invasi dai morti merda sono tutti i
fantasmi c'è soltanto una persona che
può salvarci soltanto una è quella
persona e jack sparso ciao gianni come
tutto a posto jack si è pieno di
fantasmi in giro
l'equipaggio maledetto completato
perfetto 24 st wright
direi che ci può pensare jack a tutto il
casino della nave fantasma davy jones e
tutto il resto
come al solito il nostro amico jack
sparso ci torna utile vai da lily
ok lo havok ero spesso gex falso perché
mi fa morire dal ridere chi è questo un
altro fratello di mez
ovvio è il bigfoot c'è babbo natale su
una locomotiva e c'è il bigfoot perfetto
ok ragazzi siamo sbloccati nelle nuove
zone sono quattro fortunatamente ci
servono al 36 st wright per sbloccarci
la prossima zona e direi di iniziare la
l'iceberg arbe c'è di berg
ok ragazze c'è di burke e sinceramente
non so cosa vuol dire ma proviamo
entrare allora c'è c'è il bigfoot
perfetto c'è c'è c'è il fratello di max
penso sia fratello perché è uguale
e poi c'è gandhi c'è gandhi ok
dammi un segno zodiacale da scoprire
allora direi ariete perché a rita ariete
perché il mio per questo punto milioni
mente nient'altro vai a perfetto la
messa in alto ariete perfetto sì l'avevo
capito l'ho fatta io ok sei contento
qual è il tuo segno zodiacale cerca di
trovare gli altri ok perfetto mi manca
una sfida e sblocco la un'altra strike
bonus perfetto così almeno ci arrivo più
in fretta la a30 site voglio una nuova
casa
non lo so un grattacielo ti basta perché
io ti faccio quello mi viene in mente
nient'altro vai grattacielo perfetto
centrato ok ora puoi usare ok perfetto
era un fratello di max si va via ma si
capiva casa uguale cilli si chiama cilli
nel mio intimo c'è il fratello di
maxwell
questa la gara veramente pessima
proseguo sono touch e una caverna o no
il ghiacciaio sta fondendo alzando il
livello dell'acqua trova modo per
fermarlo cos'è perché ma perché aspetta
aspetta aspetta solo aggettivo freddo ok
ce l'ho fatta favi salva la terra dallo
scioglimento dei ghiacciai perfetto c'è
una caverna che non so dove porta regno
perduto delle parentesi ma che cazzo
vuol dire
ok ci entrerò dopo raga perché voglio
vedere cosa c'è davanti comunque non ha
senso c'è sensei buongiorno voglio
scolpire questo blocco di ghiaccio
scalpello scaletta stavo scrivendo
scaletto vabbè scalpello gigante
perfetto mai perfetto artista polare
fantastico c'è il bigfoot che non
sorridi a voi una foto perfetto allora
foto macchina fotografica
ok stai fermo facciamoci la foto tipo
bimbiminkia perfetto
accidenti lo yeti e mangiato la tua foto
no perché c'è quale vi da photoshop per
mangiarla ten è fabbricato 1 a sto punto
fatemi fare soltanto una foto al cigno
perché fantastico perfetto e poi oddio
io faccio le foto al signore e le mangio
al big foot va bene
regno perduto delle parentesi perfetto
ok che cazzo di cos'è una roba sommersa
e tipo atlantide star
ok c'è un carabiniere con la maschera va
beh c'è indiana jones
cosa vuole l'arca dell'alleanza addio
mai veramente indiana jones aveva detto
raga ma secondo me scrive nord ci sono
un casino di riferimenti ai film e robe
del genere tipo quelli di prima appunto
lo sapevo che non mi sbagliavo perché
evidentissimo vabbè comunque anche
dell'alleanza deve essere da queste
parti porta mela e vabbè faccio io
indiana favi ok lo trovate l'ho già
trovata la prima da vuoto oddio
ok non dovevo svuotarla perfetto torna
dentro brutto stronzo
devo portatile diana jones vabbè
facciamo finta di non aver liberato
nessuno gliela porta vuota tanto non se
ne accorgerà mai perfetto
tieni metti dentro o catturato indiana
jones
perfetto allora lasciamo perdere perché
non ha senso lo catturato indiana jones
non so perchè spezza la maledizione di
mettendo le pietre sulle proprie colonne
rimettendo le pietre sulle proprie
colonne che cazzo vuol dire ok c'è una
rodio vieni più vicino per attivarmi
guardandomi voglia avvicinare perché c'è
quella fare lì mi avvicino a poco poco è
ok perfetto si sta già incazzando quindi
muoviamoci
muoviti brutta stronza città non
sommerso scopi che ha prosciugato
l'oceano ok
in che senso città non sommersa non l'ho
capita l'avete tanto vediamo adesso
ok qualcuno ha tirato via l'acqua
perfetto ok la città è stata prosciugata
dalla lega degli scienziati pazzi di
staino e scienziato come una creatura
leggendaria a sto punto direi non lo so
ciclope
la prima cosa ne è venuto in mente mai
perfetto che cazzata la fisica nucleare
è stanca di studiare l'uranio indica un
nuovo elemento su cui fare ricerche raga
non so che cosa devo creare sinceramente
ma voglio provare con l'antimateria
antimateria è fantastica sta cosa c'è da
piccolo cenno fissa lo st wright può
essere preso sembra così facile ok
cosa vuol dire eccolo lo trovato
raccogli non è che un altro made in
china tipo quello che avevo fatto
all'inizio quando è un falso sarete il
cancello si è chiuso lo sapevo ci avrei
scommesso
vabbè allora lo possiamo perfetto questa
porta si apre solo per gli scienziati
pazzi vesti max con due oggetti per
ingannare la telecamera monocolo
perfetto il monocolo funziona sempre
sono convinto e poi direi tipo camicie
esso punto vai l'effetto si regga sembra
vagamente il professor hoc comunque sto
scienziato il travestimento ingannato
dal sorveglianza e cancelli adesso
distruggere la tubatura
ok sto praticamente facendo un casino
raga direi che un martello martello
gigante è quello che ci sia o dio peggio
di quello di thor che attacca beh oddio
uscita una dinamite perché lo scienziato
pazzo in realtà un robot predisposto per
otto distruggersi trova un modo per
contenere l'esplosione di e bender
non lo so cosa devo fare by beccano mai
ok no sto moretto merda mi sta facendo
il culo
ok raga fermi il secondo mi è venuta
un'idea per fermarlo perché se non
riesco allora mina vado a piazza una
mina a terra spero che lo becchi perché
se no non so come fare sono in trappola
ok ok ragazzi elettrificato non so
perché ok perfetto ci siamo è esploso da
solo si sta riempiendo tutto d'acqua di
nuovo sia elettrificato raga non so come
è successo ma vabbè apriamo apriamo sta
roba prima che a fuoco e prendiamo la st
wright siamo a 27
me ne mancano tre ragazze posso
sbloccare la zona nuova direi che posso
chiudere qui per questo episodio perché
la mia voce veramente mi sta chiedendo
pietà
vi ricordo comunque che i prossimi
episodi che usciranno i prossimi video
specialmente con le sabato intanto qua
c'è stop asilo da vero che un altro pomi
sbrana e ancora dentro indiana jones
eccola liberato indiana già o dio è
morto perché è morto
ok direi che posso chiudere qui prima
che la mia voce prenda al controllo di
me stesso inizia insultarmi da solo sei
video è piaciuto come al solito lasciato
un commento vi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione se non siete ancora
iscritti iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazzi